Medical appointments would be scheduled during business hours,
and I knew that I would need time off to recover from surgical procedures.
Again, being a typical lawyer,
I had done my due diligence on what to expect from treatment.
Admittedly, a lot of that was through Doctor Google,
perhaps not my best move and I wouldn't recommend that.
(Laughter)
But while I was ready for all the physical side effects,
what really scared me was this thing called chemo brain.
Chemo brain presents itself through memory loss,
an inability to concentrate
and an inability to solve problems.
And if this happened to me,
I wondered how I was going to do my job as a lawyer.
Would I be forced to leave work?
And how could I possibly have a discussion with my manager
about reasonable adjustments to my working arrangements
when I didn't know how I was going to be impacted?
I was fortunate to have a supportive manager
who was happy to see how things went as we went along,
rather than requiring a concrete plan up front.
I was lucky that while he may not have even known
about this concept of reasonable adjustments,
to him, it was just common sense.
But I've learned that it's not common sense to everyone.
Everyone going through treatment will learn how it impacts them
and what their limitations are.
And they'll learn to adjust for that.
So for me, there were the tips and tricks that I learned about the treatment itself,
like, before you go to chemo,
you need to make sure you're really well hydrated
and that you're warm, because it helps the nurses to find your veins.
And make sure that you don't eat any of your favorite food,
either before or after chemo,
because you're going to be throwing that up
and you won't ever want to look at it again.
(Laughter)
I learned that one the hard way.
And then there were the tricks for managing my workflow.
I scheduled chemo for first thing on a Monday morning.
I knew that from the time I left the cancer care unit,
I had about four hours before this fog screen would come down
and I would start to be sick.
So I would use that time to clean my inbox and make any urgent calls.
The worst of the sickness would be gone within about 48 hours.
And then I would log back into work from home.
This treatment continued and I knew what to expect.
I was able to set reasonable expectations with my business partners
about what I could do
and the time frames that I could do it in.
But I still remember the hesitation in their voices
when it came to asking for things.
And asking me to do things by a certain time.
And trust me, these were people
that were not afraid of setting a good deadline.
(Laughter)
I got the impression they didn't want to put any extra pressure on me
while I was going through treatment.
And while I appreciated the sentiment,
I actually needed the deadlines.
To me, that was something within my control
and something that could stay in my control
when there were so many things that couldn't.
And as I was working from home,
I was thinking about how employers should be applying this concept
of reasonable adjustments in our current age,
where one in two Australian men and women
will be diagnosed with cancer by the age of 85.
So, as we continue to work longer and longer into older age,
the chances of having a serious illness while we're in the workforce
are increasing.
And with technology enabling us to work anywhere, any time,
reasonable adjustments are no longer contingent upon
whether or not you can continue to physically make it
into the physical office.
Reasonable adjustments are also not about
just offering a longer break or a comfier chair to sit in,
although those things might be good, too.
At the very least,
we need to be applying the flexibility policies and strategies
we've developed for other scenarios,
like for people with family responsibilities.
But how can we ensure that people are even having a conversation
about what reasonable adjustments might look like for them
if a manager's first response is to say,
"Oh no, don't come back to work until you're better."
And a light went on for me.
It must be compulsory for managers
to have to have these conversations with their employees.
And lessons from people like me,
that have really benefited from working through treatment,
need to be more widely shared.
And I thought about what could be done to guide these conversations,
and then an amazing colleague of mine, Camilla Gunn,
developed a "Working with Cancer" toolkit.
The toolkit provides a framework for those diagnosed,
their managers, their carers and their coworkers
to have conversations about cancer and the work support available.
Camilla and I have now been to other organizations
to talk about the toolkit
and how it can help to guide through
what, quite frankly, are otherwise some pretty awkward conversations.
And I'm pleased to say that the uptake of the toolkit is increasing.
So what should be a manager's first response
when somebody says that they're sick
and they don't know how it's going to impact their work?
It must be this:
"To the extent that you are able, and want to,
we would love to work out an arrangement for you
to continue to work through treatment."
We need to start positively engaging people with serious illness
to keep them in the workforce,
rather than paternalistically pushing them away.
I've told you my story because I want you to know the benefits
that working through treatment brought me.
And I also want to change your perceptions
if you think that somebody going through treatment
is just bored, frail and vomiting a lot.
And yes, these things were true some of the time,
if not a lot of the time,
but I was also determined to push myself at work
as much as I had always done.
And I was able to do that because my employer gave me the choice.
Most importantly, I'm telling you
because while it's a seemingly obvious choice to give someone,
it's not one that is always offered or encouraged.
And it must be.
Thank you.
(Applause)